a lava no entanto é então vem fantini
ciência de dor é neurociência é e para
votar na minha formação é e eu sou
médica e neste momento não faz sentindo
só nossa paciência
é o que não é muito comum e não é muito
comum sobretudo quando toda a gente à
minha volta e américa portanto eu sou
assim quem sai um carinho quem abandonou
carinho barco tinha os pais dizem sempre
transitar emenda é mas então por que na
ciência antes de falar particularmente
dor que é um tema muito interessante
digo por quê porque nasci pra mim não é
nada mais interessante do que a
neurociência
não existe a menor chance pra mim
começou aqui no universo nos passos
naquilo que existe que existiu e que vai
esse tipo de teoria será física sempre
que ser astrofísica achava espaço
incrível é complexo é desconhecido tá em
trilhões galaxy s galaxy tem 100 bilhões
de estrelas
eu quero saber mais sobre isto então os
meus pais eram uns copos um escavadeira
12 dos copos o meu pai pobre e é sempre
comigo as quintas-feiras ao planetário
por conhecer mais sobre as brancas o
brasil sempre saber se vai ser bom o
shopping ganhou paulo e eu fui pra mim
foi falar em sinhá ao site onde fica a
faculdade medicina incrível foi muito
bom estudar em coimbra e é mais ou menos
a mãe do meu curso eu percebi que era
uma coisa mais interessante do que os
níveis e não sei se outra vez os alemães
thomas tem pena eu acho que é mesmo a
mesma coisa mais interessante com níveis
porque quando nós dizemos conviver com
universa triliões a três galáxias e
muitas estrelas
esquecemos de uma coisa que não sei
livro existem 100 bilhões de neurônios e
que estes neurônios não existem sozinhos
eles comunicam com milhares de outros
neurônios numa piada quem é mais
complexa que existe o nosso cérebro é o
jeito mais completo que existe no
universo portanto desculpe mas o
universo não seria tão interessante como
mãe
se não fosse o nosso cérebro e é por
isso que estou na neurociência
particularmente deixamos nunca
o neurônio e as redes funcionamento e
passando por aquilo que eu com 16 que
quando comecei a fazer um ensino um dos
grande problemas comigo por ai que dó
concentrador a dor é filha várias formas
ou se agora para vocês fazerem um
exercício em seus clipes vocês pensarem
que dó que dó
quando você vai pensar o que dó eu
garanto que aquilo que quero vocês
pessoal é completamente diferente
lucas ou estava só pessoa a dor é
diferente para toda a gente pela nossa
morte apenas da dor que tivemos quando
éramos crianças da dor que vimos a nossa
mãe nosso pai na sua vou ter a toda hora
de frente pra toda a gente
nós conhecemos a dor há milhares de anos
nós conhecemos a dor há muito mais tempo
do que por exemplo conheci anos o que é
uma leucemia
no entanto existem tratamentos de ponta
para leucemia anticorpos que vão atuar
na mui perfeitamente e não consegue
tratar da orgânica
não há hipótese 30 por cento da
população portuguesa tem dor
este dor crônica e não conseguimos
tratar disso então por que o que dói a
dor transtornos avira a dor da casa vida
de muita gente o que é estuprador fato
como eu disse nós conhecemos a durar
muito tempo e de kart
não sei quantos aceito nós temos esse
sangue é incrível e mesmo assim nem na
altura não conseguimos lutador tem este
fato incrível
temos três anos em 17 c e sabe
administrar porque nós temos dó nós
temos aqui uma fogueira existe aqui uma
fogueira e nós vamos pôr o pé no fundo
vai manter o acerto indiretamente no
exterior e vamos tirar o pé porque nós
temos em todo nosso corpo nossa pelas
receitas que são neurônios são os
conceitos livros e membro da ciência os
novos setores esses efeitos vão receber
um estímulo
teoricamente inox e pra nós é um estilo
que vai provocar uma usam como se fosse
uma queimadura tentamos pôr o pé numa
fogueira
estes setores então vão receber essa
informação e vão transmitir é sempre uma
semana outro neurônio
lançando luís outro neurônio vai
transmitir essa informação não seguro
nós sempre vai dizer não há ali qualquer
coisa que vai fazer mas vamos tirar o pé
e portanto exterior ea perspectiva nós
morremos não tivesse melhor é não ter
dor faz com que expresse vira diminua
muito mas sim uma genética é que a
síndrome de análise é congênita
pretender que as pessoas não têm dó não
sentem dó eventualmente morrem na
segunda década de vida portanto qualquer
quero é acidente qualquer pequeno
estímulo pov facto é usarmos muito
grande porque a pessoa não suportei
pintura nossa amiga protejam a dor
inteiro nos fato de nos lábios
no entanto no entanto apesar disso e
apesar de com aquele estilo del valle a
dor
nós nem sempre sentimos a dor da mesma
forma e que entrou no nosso cérebro é um
estímulo último vai até não ser o nosso
cérebro diz não estou a fim de causar
mau cheiro aqui vamos fugir vamos fazer
alguma coisa porque isto é a dor está
mal estar que eu tenho que sair daqui
mas não é bem assim
o cérebro não ver sempre o sistema da
mesma forma irresponsável produz coisas
essenciais redor perfeição e plano do
san siro conselho modular os times estão
em áfrica neste momento num safári uma
volta e quando volta o e aí urgentes
serão agora traz certa a gente vê o que
acontece no cérebro do caia é simpático
mas mesmo assim simpático leva nos a
correr leva-nos a fugir e nós não
sentimos adoro
da mesma forma para verem o 50/50
imaginem e 50
o nosso bem agora é bom não é
dói acho que sim nem que não quis
comentar mas agendou bom posso garantir
uma coisa ela tem 50 quilos não estar
bem na ativa e exatamente ético vai sair
pra frente
ela está ativada exatamente os mesmos
conceitos exatamente nos concertos do
european cup os 50 que os estava ativado
ou seja exatamente ela vai acabar esta
doença e observatórios em grave e não
dói nada
na falta de prazer de lançar isto porque
o nosso cérebro pega neste estilos e
através de nomes consciência de unção e
obsessão conceito modular o estímulo
doloroso
portanto não será essencial na dor e por
que nós não estamos a tratar bem a dor
porque não estamos a tratar no sítio
certo
estamos a tratar é preferir não estamos
a tratar fato as alterações cerebrais
que acontecem e temos aquecida causa a
vida tal é era uma senhora com dor
crônica
o indicador se torne crônica quando não
precisamos nos time não precisa vestir
um nosso cérebro é autosuficiente em
geral redor
tanto que o ps 50 quilos no vasto
deserto
tirem mas ainda continua financeiro fez
um empreendimento houve qualquer coisa
que determinou que eu não esqueço do
amor e dor continuou sempre existir vai
existir sempre independentemente de
haver ou não um último e é isso que a
filha causas em água portanto neste
neste quinto neste quadro ela desenha o
que sentes ela sente no corpo não é nada
mas elas entre os espinhos no córtex
cerebral giradouro o cérebro que é
autossuficiente senador tanto e estudar
estudar o cérebro indoor tanto é aquilo
que eu faço é ver como é que o cérebro
funciona através da ressonância
magnética uma técnica que sumissem
magnética funcional em que nós tiramos
através da forma como o sangue vai para
os diferentes - terceiro nós vamos
colocar em funcionamento e vemos fato
como funciona o cérebro do doente com dó
ataque não preciso ler o que é
interessante este modelo ainda que o
estudo indica que está a ser feito em
chicago também é por isso que há pessoas
que depois de terem que o estilo até o
tal estilo quanto subjetivo
tem opções têm maior probabilidade de
ficar com dor ou seja as pessoas têm uma
maior predisposição ter dor crônica
e esse tipo de som do piano do
funcionamento do nosso cérebro
dependendo do mecanismo de recompensa as
pessoas que têm menos organismos
recompensa - e ficasse uns têm maior
probabilidade de ficar com dor crônica
também estuários o facto tentar predizer
com base no funcionamento do cérebro
quem tem maior probabilidade mantedor
quando não há um estímulo importante era
isso que eu tinha para dizer se era isso
que eu tinha para falar acerca da dor é
o nosso cérebro e sem dúvida
sem dúvida o objeto mais fascinantes do
universo
não sabemos muito sabemos muito pouco o
fato nós conseguirmos ver o cérebro
funcionar
conseguimos ver há cerca de 20 anos com
a ressonância magnética funcional tem
vindo a convulsionar muita coisa e eu
espero antaq e dois ou três anos já ter
novidades este trabalho factos
recorrendo ao invalidar é muitas
respostas
portanto todos quero você se tem neste
momento o objeto mais complexo universo
dentro do acesso não tenho dúvidas
nenhuma virada
[Aplausos]
[Música]